[Music]
this is star talk sports edition today
we're going to talk about counting cards
stuff that the casinos hate about you if
you have the talent to pull that off I
got with me as always my co-host Chuck
Knight jacket baby hey what's happening
all right professional standard comedian
and actor and game show host and uh
brain games on National Geographic very
cool yes and the one person who is
actual professional athletic street cred
Among Us Gary O'Reilly Gary always good
to have you here man pleasure's mine
thank you Neil thanks for making us
legit so Gary what I mean card counting
we've all heard about it we've seen
movies about it we wish we had that
ability and again we don't know if you
can be trained for it and so you decided
to create a whole show on it so what do
you have in store for us today uh very
hopefully a story that will not just be
fascinating but so interesting to a
number of people we are going to meet
someone with an interesting and amazing
life story it basically starts as a
pre-teen Refugee who became a
professional blackjack player on the
infamous MIT blackjack team so if you
think about the movie 21 you're kind of
in the right space as regards where this
goes we're going to try and learn the
high low system get into card steering
dive deep into computer simulations
immerse ourselves in Quantified thinking
um but let me take you back to the early
90s this MIT blackjack group were
basically setting the stage in the way
that they thought approached
the kind of put the money ball mindset
in place 10 or so years prior so we may
well touch on that and but these days if
we fast forward Our Guest is a mentor an
entrepreneur an angel investor and it
even has the time to run marathons so
let's meet semian ducash one time
professional blackjack player as I've
said studied computer science at
Columbia and MIT founder and co-founder
of several companies over the past 30
odd years including fast endings which
he did sell for a handy chunk of change
and good for him and his current Project
one-way Ventures is a venture capital
fund which invests in early stage
startups with at least one immigrant on
the founding team and that is something
we will certainly be touching on later
in the show I want to hear more about
that for sure we'll get there in time so
uh please meet our guest Simeon welcome
to StarTalk
thank you thanks for having me excellent
excellent so uh we know you have a very
busy schedule thanks for carving on time
for this for this for this conversation
I'm gonna call it an interview but it's
not an interview we're gonna chill
with you for like the next 45 minutes so
uh there's been a film made and books
based on you and documentaries about
your life and so how do you go from
being a computer science early early
computer science geek to card to cards
or blackjacks like what what is the how
do you go from A to B in that
conversation
oh well uh one day in 1991 I was walking
down infinite Corridor in MIT and I saw
a poster on the wall and the poster said
make ten thousand dollars over the
summer play Blackjack in Old Vegas
casinos
and you know that sounded pretty good
wait just to be clear
um MIT you could probably get away with
that but but there could be some places
where that same sign would say this
summer lose ten thousand dollars
the casino right but MIT is probably one
of the few places where the poster would
be believed but believable poster right
that's right and you know the truth is I
I'm not sure I would have believed it
except I happen to play a lot of Pac-Man
when I was a kid in Texas and uh you
know the video game and so one day I
went to the library and when I I needed
to make my quarter last a very long time
because I I couldn't get a second
quarter you know it was just one quarter
to be had
um and so I went to the library and I
found I looked up books on Pac-Man and
it was only one book uh by this guy
named kendallston I read the book and I
was able to play it back when a long
long time until I didn't feel like
playing a little bit more uh but then I
went back and and noticed that he had a
bunch of other books all these other
books were Blackjack so he was this one
of these guys that was able to beat I
guess the casinos in Atlantic City when
they first opened up about a decade
before before I played wait so all this
started because you tried to milk a
quarter for as much Pac-Man time as you
could get from it
that's right this is this this is so
very important right now for all of you
parents out there to to take note okay
because we all think that video games
are deleterious to our children's mental
health and to their academic academics
and uh we say oh you're going to ruin
Yourself by playing these video games
but it's really not about the video
games it's about the child the kid so if
your kid ever says I'm going to the
library to get some books on video games
they're gonna be okay I mean that kid's
gonna be all right
as long as they're telling the truth
because
somewhere else right forget about it so
send me on okay so you go from Pac-Man
to Blackjack it's a pretty big leap so
you must have had some kind of
superpower somewhere up your sleeve so
so what is it is it Total Recall
concentration or do you just have to be
good with numbers what's the deal there
forever
I mean the superpower I think was
twofold well one was I guess that I I
had but notice that I might go to the
library and read something that's
already right like that's the privileged
background right the examples set in the
youth I think that I had right I had
educated parents
um the other superpower I think maybe
was just not being able to get that
second quarter like having the
motivation uh to read the book and then
later having the motivation to work my
ass off like when I saw it when I met
the Amity black team having read a book
about it you know I felt like it was a
very lucky opportunity that actually
admit these people you know and I wanted
to make money I wanted to make a lot
more than ten thousand dollars I needed
to it was a real you know goal for me at
the time
um no it's not necessarily the best goal
for young men to have but to me at the
time you know that was the goal we were
poor right like we lived in a project
itself and um you know that was the main
that was the main differentiated just
the willingness to work my ass off and
like do this stuff over and over and
over and over again there was no rocket
science there was no matter genius you
know I mean coming yeah
a lot of knowledge and intelligence but
I actually didn't come up with them you
know I I was thought I would do it and
then I ended up you know running my own
group and teaching English and other
people how to do it but it was all about
like diligence hard work record keeping
for sure uh and just you know beating
things over and over and over again
until they got them right so there's
another thing for you parents out there
to understand okay is if you are doing
okay maybe you are a middle class or
middle middle class upper middle class
okay
let your children be poor
don't give your children any money
you know
be like Dad can I get some sneakers he'd
be like go ahead I'll be like okay can I
have the money and be like you you want
sneakers you go get them and then I
would say and I would say but Dad we
have money and then he would say no son
I have money I earn the money you are
broke you are poor you don't have crap
see so you there you go
all right let's let's jump from being
really incentivized to make this thing
successful you then have to you must
have to acquire a certain skill set
um are we are we into game series here
do you start to deploy those sort of
things or is it something different
again or probabilities as well is it
yeah
no there's none of those things
it had to be something that had to be
snoozing
I don't know I just did it I don't know
like 20 years ago these books and
stories about what we did came out and I
did a lot of interviews and you know
people always wanted to hear about the
Mastery and stuff and I kind of played
it along but at this point you know I'll
tell it to you like it really was okay
we could have trained anybody to do it
it was the same as like the math skills
required were you know second grade
level like literally counting like three
four five five fourth leads to you know
um just keeping track of like one number
and adding one subtracting one and just
not getting distracted now that's the
level of skills that were required the
rest of it was just memorizing A system
that other people already came up with
it was pretty rudimentary it it required
discipline it required not drinking
while you're doing it stuff like that it
didn't require any great theoretical
mathematical thinking not losing it so
I'm really attached to this story
because my father was a gambler and I
don't mean like he gambled I mean he was
a gambler that sounds like a blue song
ready to be written my father was a
Gambling Man
you went to hold him and went to walk
away yeah
didn't always win
we got a number one on our hands but the
funny thing is that uh he did count
cards and I don't I don't know the
system that he used but uh it was and
and maybe Simeon could tell me what it
is but it basically was
there's account it's plus one zero or
minus one that's all he did and uh you
bet according to where the count is
where uh the number of decks and the
cards that are in the debt and you had
just have to have the discipline to bet
wisely during the entire shoe and you
know to know when to bet when the count
is up down or at zero I mean that's I
never did it so that's what I understood
him to be doing but there were times I
would see him make a crap ton of money
and then there were times that you know
uh that led to him being divorced uh
from my mother
and his dog left him
yeah
I'm not sure those two as related with
all that you know
your mother can can lead to getting
divorced but making a whole bunch of
money could also lead together you're
absolutely right you're right about that
you're right about that okay so if you
didn't do anything we're asking you what
did what did you do
that's what I did I did the same thing
about it I think the difference was that
we had a group of people who are very
diligent about doing it people kind of
learn sort of things they can kind of do
it right we tested people all the time
we checked their skills not only once
but before each trip uh it you have a
very small Advantage right and it takes
a long time to get to the long term and
in any short period of time you could
win no lose it's kind of random right
but you have like this tiny little one
percent Edge or half a percentage and
after a month so even years of playing
you're gonna know you're going to be a
debt and yeah in the real world people
get distracted people get tired right
people get emotional about how they wins
the losses yes and they give it from the
system without even realizing it so
that's the same thing what distinguished
us as real professionals from the many
thousands of other people who kind of
enjoy and it's funny because the the
casino does that but they don't need the
discipline because the house rules don't
change no matter what but the house
rules are set up so that this slight
percentage of advantage that they have
means that over the long term they're
always going to win over the long term
as a casino well it just may be clear
what what he said was Chuck that there
are fluctuations from hand to hand yeah
even from day to day that can go up or
down but if you stay diligent with the
system right the small percent that you
gain against the average will accumulate
and then you can basically Bank those
winnings reliably and that's that's the
deal and they call that having long
money you got to have long money long
money okay so Simeon in the intro I
talked about high low system and Cloud
steering so break down Cloud steering
for me because I think we've realized
now that if you're going to play
Blackjack you have got to have Ninja
light concentration and as they say
always watching so can you just even
just just for me and the rest of our
audience that don't know Cloud steering
please unlock that for us Gary we'll get
to that question after the break because
I know sorry see what I did there yeah
keep them hanging keep them hanging all
right so I I want to know what this is
too because I've never even heard of it
before this moment so when we return to
Star talk sports edition we're gonna
tell you how to beat the casino I think
yeah black let's find out but we'll be
right back with our special guest card
counter extraordinaire
on StarTalk
we're back with Simeon
Neil deGrasse Tyson here StarTalk sports
edition Simeon dukach is an MIT computer
scientist entrepreneur and who made his
Mark counting cards in blackjack and
we're trying to get to the bottom of
this but how did it happen where where
it came from what special talents it was
and by the way it's not illegal to count
cards it's just casinos don't like it
when you do that because it tips things
in your favor instead of their favor so
this brings us to our first question how
did you get out of Vegas with both of
your knees
still in your legs okay so send me on I
need you to Define for a certain terms
we went into we went into the break with
Gary asking you about what was it Gary
so uh there's a couple of techniques and
I I'm semi I'm sure we'll we'll be able
to as I said unlock those for us one in
particular which sounds very interesting
card still hearing card steering so uh
if you want not only that I want to know
about Quantified thinking there's all
these terms we're going to get there
yeah okay good it says card steering so
Simeon what do you got for us there so
we have a number of uh let's say more
advantages more complicated techniques
that I think the theory could generate a
bigger Advantage than the one percent or
so Advantage you can get with Carter
running and so a card steering was a few
variations of it sometimes involves a
tracking sequences of cards through the
shot hole roughly being able to kind of
see the they might be four or five cars
in between each and the sequence after
shuffling and kind of predict when the
last one is Gonna Come uh it wasn't
always possible right
um sometimes I could seek the last card
I want to show after all the shuffling
is done and then when you cut the cards
we would learn to cut a precise number
of cars like exactly 52 cars let's say
Zapped in deck from the back of the shoe
and then we will know that the back card
will come out number 52 right and that's
exactly how many you cut which you could
get good at by just practicing for hours
later cutting exactly hips into cars
don't people get shot for this
but not so much in the corporate run
public company around Vegas
in the Vegas of the 60s or 70s yeah I
would have wouldn't have worked very
well and we did play a lot
internationally and there were some
places where we probably shouldn't have
played
um but you think there's nothing that
was legal we didn't we didn't uh you
know violate any rules to the game it
didn't cheat which was important because
we didn't get out all the time caught
all the time so have you done anything
illegal over the frosting you to us
certainly uh so we're very careful not
not to break the law you were running
computer simulations you were
replicating Live casino environments so
as your blackjack players would be
comfortable and not dazzled by a casino
environment I mean this basically is
almost when you say you analyzed results
you looked at things and you weren't
just looking at successes you were
looking at failures now then if you
apply Quantified thinking how do you
approach this group of data and then
bring It Forward successfully for you
yeah that's a really good question I'll
give you an example because that's some
of the work that actually distinguished
us from some of the other groups that
were less successful right it wasn't
those cards Theory and invest techniques
because those ended up not working most
of the time honestly they were they only
worked in certain situations at the end
of the day it would have made the money
do anything the world or caracality
techniques have already been written
about but we did it more diligently and
I think
running simulations to to predict you
know how much you should have won uh in
order to kind of track what really
happened and then running these
examinations basically where in in our
own sort of classroom environment we'll
try to distract people right we would
have one person test another person but
someone else will be distracting them
like trying to talk to them trying to
you know offer them drinks or whatever
happens in the real casino and uh we
would try how many mistakes people would
make people would always invariably make
some mistakes in accounting like they
just weren't perfect they couldn't see
every single card right and so we would
get a better understanding model of the
real life performance of of the card
calendar in the casino rather than the
theoretical performance that you know
the books say you're gonna have and So
based on that we would know the right
amount to bet and the right way to play
I mean now that made all the difference
right it's using that data and being
realistic about our own capabilities but
from one decade to another computers
gain speed and precision and accuracy
and algorithms get better so did any of
this improve over the decades from the
90s to today for example
probably to some extent but I I would
say
you know we've never used computers in
the casino or anything like that like
that that probably would be shooting uh
we did more than any of those kinds of
things we merely used them to better
analyze and better understand how we
should be playing and I think yeah I'm
sure there were improvements but uh for
the most part I think the technology was
sufficient at the time to be able to
improve discipline right and to be able
to model how we will perform
realistically in a casino environment
and and design the tests that really had
to apply to each other to make sure that
we were good enough because you really
had to be very precise you couldn't make
very many errors right right semian if
we look at if we look at sport they're
they're Quantified thinking they're data
analytics they analyze different things
now different metrics than the ones they
did 10 20 years ago what were what would
you be looking at now that you weren't
looking at back then in the 90s that
would change the game even more
you know I don't understand I haven't
given much sauce to the game well I mean
the one thing that's changed uh
dramatically in many casinos
um and I'm not particularly sure if it's
because of
um you know uh people like Simeon but I
it's the auto shuffler
um
uh combined with eight decks and the
auto shuffler shuffles after like so
many hands not even it doesn't go an
entire shoe it's like you you pick it up
you put it back in it's shuffled like
after three hands or sometimes you'll
see that they do it on it looks random
like is it I'm not even sure if the
dealer is just instructed to do it or if
they're just like ah just do it just do
it you know but that's that's gotta have
changed things tremendously for card
counters well that's right because
Simeon I you know when you're just
playing at home it's one deck of cards
and so you can get a sense whether the
the remaining cards to be dealt or or
Royal heavy or you know low card heavy
you get a sense of that but with eight
decks how can you possibly know that you
get a slip in the same exactly you know
it's just that uh with one deck of cards
let's say three look 3DX still little
cards came out and you know their City
extra big cards left in the down okay so
there's a date decks you're going to
want to see a lot more you're going to
want to see like 20 or 25 little extra
cards to come out the witch will still
happen the same traction at the time
right like you just have to play long
enough until that happens and then you
bet a lot so it's no different it's the
numbers are just a little larger but you
do have to reset every time they reset
your your brain computer every time they
Shuffle because yeah yeah and that's
right so so they have another question
yes if they start shuffling all the time
you can still work and but however this
isn't like a modern instrument the
casinos new about cars accountancy since
the 60s
um they occasionally make the room rules
and there's a bunch of other rule
variations besides shuffling that they
can do to make card counting that work
very well but the thing is
millions of people know about car coding
it's it's marketing for the game like
Blackjack makes more money than any
other card game you know really anything
else besides slot machines precisely
because people know it could be beat and
so I think uh there's competitions
between casinos they players players who
think they're doing a little car coding
you know they want the best possible
rules they don't want the house the
whole time in 99 of all those money and
so the casinos eventually gravitate it
back to making the game be beatable at
the edge as long as it's only beatable
by a small number of people it kind of
works so
end of the longer those the rare people
who could actually beat the game don't
start betting table maximum you know
which is what we did right that's
because of the problem
but that's brilliant what you're saying
is that
um they use their vulnerability as a
market tool as bait yeah it's right yeah
you know we don't know yeah we're not
going to shuffle it all the time come on
in and play take you know you got a
better chance here come on and sit down
and play because they're still gonna win
that's exactly it the most people
they're still gonna learn okay send me
on the MIT blackjack Club was just
famous Infamous choose it whichever way
you wish
but you're a professional blackjack
player you are you've left 10 grand
during the summer way behind in the rear
view mirror why then if you're doing
this successfully did you decide to walk
away
that's a good question too so it wasn't
because I was kicked out of all the
casinos and The Jig was up because Alexa
kept out of all the casinos very quickly
and continue doing it anyway or because
you're missing your kneecaps as chuck
had yeah there were a few threats here
and there but really they're big public
corporations that they generally just
don't do that anymore
um it's not really worth it for them
right we don't really win that much
um
I got bored of it right I just started
feeling like it was kind of pointless
you know it sounds like we really made
that much money it was a few million
dollars it wasn't it seemed like a lot
of it yeah
it's a few million bucks I mean
seriously that's the board line yeah but
mine that's Chuck that's a few million
that's a few million dollars in the
early 90s yeah yeah that's real money
back then back to that into today
what else happened in that time period
okay so and where we came home so yeah
we were the MIT blackjack team right I
was studying computer science so several
others in my own particular specific
example I was in the process of
completing a PhD dissertation uh on the
very first way to transfer money over
the Internet like that's the thing I
published it you know you could look it
up like the people who didn't started
PayPal for example right they cited my
paper as literally I worked it wasn't
very good perhaps but it was fair
technology work better but it's because
I quit right to play Blackjack so no I
in retrospect the I mean the one million
dollars that are personally made and the
five million dollars the whole group
made well not at all interesting or
significant and we have multiple people
come out of the group that became
billionaires in technology yeah so we
just wasted a bunch of time financially
speaking but then there was a whole
other side okay we didn't generate any
value they had no customers nobody ever
said Thank you right we just moved money
from one place to another and we felt
really smart because we thought we were
smarter than this people who worked for
the casinos and you know okay so we were
smarter than these people but you know
so what like that's not really something
to me particularly proud of right it's
interesting what you're really talking
about here is where he grew a conscience
well more than that is is it's the value
of purpose
in what we do yes the value of purpose
in in your endeavors probably outweighs
any uh financial gain that you might
glean from what it is that you do Chuck
the life counselor I love it
and the world looks kind of funny that
way right because
um if you actually follow the sense of
purpose and you have seen succeed and
Excel at that right and uh deliver a lot
of value to people who you want to help
and and get their graduates in the
series right you're going to end up
making way more money than if you're
just starting to make money like at the
end of the day you're going to do better
anyway so yeah
the the MIT blackjack team basically was
a hot house
for future entrepreneurs was it just by
chance that this happened or do you
think playing Blackjack the way that you
did as a team was enabling people to
develop certain parts in the future wait
wait just to be clear to think about
Gary Gary we're talking about MIT here
computer science people at the birth of
an entire internet so and more than that
it's among the good size people there's
lots of people who just became
programmers with Microsoft right this is
the computer science people who wanted
to take risk who wanted to be
entrepreneurial to think outside of the
box to tackle something that's supposed
to be impossible right these are all
personal characteristics
entrepreneurs yeah that's what I'm
thinking was the case here so this this
this game of blackjack attracted a
certain thinker a certain Dynamic within
a person that then found another path to
take itself forward so after that like
it was the commercial that's the door
the fact that we're not trying to make
money rather than playing yeah or or
play with paper specifically motivated
by generating profits so that
combination right of the quantity is
taking and discipline and diligence and
the desire to do well financially ended
up being very lucrative was any of it to
sticking it to the man you know oh yeah
you know do you know casinos
definitely yeah that was a big part of
it a big part of it because you wouldn't
do that to a homeless shelter uh like
you would you do it to a casino right
because that's exactly right I mean we
really did you know there was also a
sense of teamwork there was a little bit
of a war going on I was like I think
that's them and we were the good guy
who tripped all the poor people all that
money exactly right
mystery drinks and we ate enough we
really hated them all right all right
guys you got to take a quick break but
when we come back more conversation with
Simeon ducats we're gonna find out what
uh what floats his boat today because
it's not the car counting anymore but
he's doing some really cool stuff we're
gonna find out when we return
we're back start call sports edition and
we've got our our special guest today
MIT alumnus uh Simeon ducat and Simeon
do you have a social media presence are
you do you lead the private life of some
no no it is
on Twitter so
s-e-m-y-o-n Simeon ducatch
d-u-k-a-c-h we'll find you there on
Twitter so so Gary take us take this
thing home where are we going okay so
we've we've walked away from the tables
with a big beaming smile on our face but
you weren't happy you've become now a
mentor
um
why was was there was The Emptiness of
being a blackjack player and just not
really having any thanks and gratitude
in your life in that regards a reason
why you went to mentoring or was there
another dynamic in play here
I would say I didn't go straight to
mentoring but I went back to technology
and I started some companies that uh
used more of my skills and knowledge
than just Blackjack
um and yeah I I definitely sensed a
contrast where customers buy my software
not only send money but would also say
thank you right and and talk about how
the software helped them solve their
problems and it felt really good right
in a way Blackjack hasn't uh but then I
also realized very quickly after a few
years by mid-year 2000 or so that I
didn't really want to build my company a
single company you know for a decade or
two I enjoyed doubling in many and I had
made some money from selling my first
one and so I started to invest it for
the first 10 or 15 years personally as
to the angel that would basically give a
Founder the early stages 50 or 100 000
my money and I would try to help them so
the mentoring came as an add-on to the
investing where putting a little money
you know tried to help however I could I
didn't often know how to help but you
know the effort the motivation really
matters they genuinely wanted to help
and over the years I would say I focused
more and more on the healthy and a
little bit less fun like buying loans
selling hacks and to the degree I got
better at that it actually ended up
being better for me financially as well
because Founders appreciate the help I
gave out and that would be referred to
other ones that would see better deals
more interesting companies than I I used
to see before then and eventually you
know I got to the point now where I ran
a venture capital fund and I have
hundreds of people behind me and it's
just a much more scalable interesting
thing so that's one way Ventures correct
explain
to us as well as our audience what the
ethos of one-way Ventures actually is
and why it's so important to you yes
about one way you know we have some
beliefs we really believe that people
from anywhere in the world should be
able to go wherever they want to build
businesses to get jobs to create value
right we fundamentally believe that we
don't think that
the U.S for instance
ought to allow more immigrants just
because on average immigrants are more
likely to create jobs and do that well
and to to basically give more than they
consuming Services over the long term I
mean up front of where the organization
Services over the long term uh there's a
lot of evidence although economists
believe that they're actually good for
the country that they arrive in and that
America is wealthier there is largely
because over the last 200 years we've
taken in a lot of immigrants so that's
all but that's not the reason we believe
that America should allow immigrants to
come here and build campaigns the reason
we think so is that we are immigrants
and we think it's our goddamn right to
come here whether you like it or not and
you know we feel very very strongly
about that we feel that
the random documents that you get based
on where you were born should not
determine your potential your outcome
your opportunities any more than the
color of your skin than any other
arbitrary thing you don't control you
don't choose to be born in America or to
be born in some other country right
you're just born where you're born and I
we think everyone wants to have equal
rights so that's why we focus on
immigrants and it also so happens that
immigrants you know make the best
entrepreneurs the majority of all very
successful companies in the US are
started by immigrants that does that's
an absolute fact about 55 of the
so-called unicorns I mean they're
Founders I'd like to add something to
that because I do this calculation
annually and it doesn't exist anywhere
else except out of my shop that the uh
if you look at the Nobel prizes and the
sciences that are given to American
citizens
a third of them have gone to immigrants
to the United States
and so that I mean that's an
extraordinary number uh far above you
know what the the fraction that
immigrants are in the United States when
you include not only those who are
legally as well as you know undocumented
you add those two up it's like 10 12 so
it's a factor of three higher than what
that is so so this is just another bit
of information there but you're saying
but but semian what you're saying there
is is not entirely realistic for let me
just so you came to the United States uh
from Moscow from Soviet Union Moscow
when basically there's a wall all right
I know the walls in Berlin but there's a
there's a philosophical wall if that
wall did not exist
and it was still the Soviet Union
I and you didn't have KGB or whatever
else and borders stopped do you think
everyone would have left the Soviet
Union the way you did
no I think most people would never leave
their tremendous social pressure your
network Community everybody wants you to
stay you in order to permanently leave
the place you grew up you're gonna have
to betray your whole communicator and
they're not gonna root for you you know
they're gonna vote you fail because
they're this and it takes a special kind
of person who is willing to take on that
hardship who has an unusual level of
ambition right believe in themselves
drive and ask to grind a chip in their
shoulder right and this is not ordinary
people so these are people who are like
highly upwardly mobile because of their
Ambitions and you're saying they should
be able to exit their country and go
anywhere in the world wherever they are
welcomed or or embraced
I just want to know why they can't come
from Norway is that so where are the
Norwegians when you need them you know
it I know it America first that's it
yeah and I think in a logic you know I
think the gentleman who said that is
severely underestimating you know the
folks that are coming here from Africa
from South America yeah I think it he's
judging though by by stereotypes they
fail to take into account that these
actually select individuals like most
people in South America don't make it to
the US even if you take the really
uneducated ones that will require a lot
more services not the focus with
computer science degrees or whatever
right but but the really important
educated people who walk like walk foot
in Caravans right and make it all the
way to the borders in Texas and Arizona
California you know they're still
extraordinary and it and I would say if
I had a construction business and I had
to hire a bunch of people for demolition
I would absolutely hire people from the
Caribbean over anybody who had an easier
time but was born here because it takes
a very extraordinary person to walk 2
000 miles on foot you know it's just
most people would not do that and so
regardless of what you think about the
group as a whole the ones who make it
over here are going to be the very very
best ones they're going to work the
hardest absolutely go through anything
to succeed those are the ones you want
yeah you know are you telling are you
saying Semion that uh an immigrant's
life story
is more predisposed to the probability
of success in a startup because of all
of the things you've just highlighted
and that's why you that's why that's why
you get involved and there isn't you
know we're able to rate the 100 million
dollars and invest it and now it's so
you know more than tripling in in the
first time beer is going to resolve the
reason uh it's working out so well is
that we actually have hard data to
support that like that
we have theories of why immigrants says
the man from MIT we got David right we
believe that there's all these reasons
that I'm talking about for why this
immigrant Founders are more likely to
build big businesses but it doesn't
really matter what we believe or what
those reasons yes 55 of the unicorns
were started by immigrants a much
smaller percentage of all companies in
America have started 55 over and half of
the unicorns were started by immigrants
that's a fact right so it's it's a
little coincidence that I said with our
this is our fund is having really great
results what you're talking about uh is
is a um an allocation of resources that
we are the beneficiary where we are the
beneficiary to this allocation of
resources people coming here and making
a contribution and I forget this
gentleman's name but he's he's uh he's
Indian
came here and somehow the the Visa
didn't work out and you know being
Indian and this was under you know this
particular
anti-immigration Administration
and I think it was the you know
um his Visa being revoked and had to
leave and so he said I here I am
I just got out of Princeton or Harvard I
forget and I'm back in India I'm
basically kicked out of the United
States where I just spent like uh 12
years in school
so what did I do well I started an
internet company it's now like the
second largest internet company you know
it's the largest in India and like third
largest in the world or in other words
what he did was he took everything that
this country had to offer
and he planted it someplace else
so you know when you allow people to
come here and you allow people to
flourish and contribute what you're
doing is making everything better you
know but the only thing that stops that
believe it or not
I'm sorry to say it is bigotry and and
and bias that's it because there is no
actual data that you can say for
instance one quick little thing and I'll
shut up oh they're bringing crime
they're bringing cry no you know these
things feel good when you say them
they're like a rallying cry but it's
[ __ ] I'm sorry it's it's it's not
true this is Chuck Martin Luther King
nice speaking to us now
all right so send me on um we've done
what you've your past we we've we've
looked up the now
what's next in your life have you have
you got this map or is it just you know
one day at a time
well uh we have a long way to go along
with one way certainly we're still
growing we're opening more locations
they're raising larger funds down the
road but this year I've spent quite a
bit of time as well over the non-profits
that I actually started with my wife in
February uh that uh so refugees from the
warning crane get a cash in their hands
to actually improve their day-to-day to
go from a sense of agency so I've made
several trips down there and I'm heading
over there again
um all right and beyond that of it I
have six kids so there's plenty of stuff
wow
wow just six
I'm gonna say you better be rich
[Music]
so this this has been a wonderful story
just to hear uh and the story is a
certain uniqueness to it so Seminole
take us out with some some some
reflective thoughts
just to make a better world because
there's a lot of crap going on out there
in the world right now what wisdom do
you have based on your life experience
well I think I think of the person you
know I mentioned earlier that when I
stopped worldwearing so much about how
can I make the most money and actually
started caring more of her about doing
some good to others together with my
existing skill set you know I was able
to do better and I think uh the party
saw that is that for half as a nation we
can do the same that if we think a
little bit more about how to make the
world a better place I want to do the
right thing right and when you think
about foreign policy you know what's
actually right or what what maximum has
a human rights not only short-term but
what best for our national insurance but
what's the right thing to do in a very
long term we're going to do the best
ourselves as well in the story it's all
about immigrants it's just one example
let's not worry about the fact that they
create walls here let's just let them in
because we reckon is their right to come
in right and what for the fall goal from
that is that they'll come here and not
somewhere else and we're gonna way
better Simeon thank you for joining us
on Star Talk that was literally fun all
right all right Gary Chuck always good
to have you there dude pleasure Neil
thank you all right this has been start
talk sports edition all about card
counting and uh doing the right thing in
the world before during and after you
take take the casino to the bank I'm
Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always keep looking up
[Music]
thank you